las vacunas de refuerzo podrían ser
clave contra la variante omicron según
resultados preliminares de las empresas
vayan tec y facer robert three stories
los estudios de laboratorio muestran que
tres dosis de nuestra vacuna neutralizan
la variante omicron mientras que dos
dosis reducen significativamente la
neutralización de esta nueva variante
just neutro live nation of
newbery and by ante qué países son los
primeros fabricantes de una vacuna
contra el cob y 19 que emiten una
actualización oficial sobre la eficacia
de su vacuna contra un micrón
hoy es un mensaje positivo que creemos
que debería calmar y reconfortar a todo
el mundo para que no se preocupe sino
que por favor vaya y se vacune 3 dosis
es realmente lo que se requiere para
protegerse eficazmente de omikron
lippert tec como metro la organización
mundial de la salud clasificó el 26 de
noviembre a un micrón como una variante
preocupante y este miércoles pidió a los
gobiernos que revisen de manera urgente
sus estrategias para contenerla las
restricciones que impiden los contagios
van a ser eficaces con un micrón o con
cualquier otra variante el resto no
únicamente pasa por la vacuna sino por
las medidas de protección de la
mascarilla la distancia física de la
higiene y las medidas restrictivas que
impiden las interacciones sociales es
papel todavía no hay datos
significativos sobre como las vacunas de
modernas johnson y johnson y otros
fabricantes se enfrentan a la nueva
variante pero se espera que publiquen
sus propios datos en las próximas
semanas